[Music]
We're JC and Holly Habber and we live uh
just south of Bell, South Dakota and we
started with JP's family operation. So
I'll let you start the story. Uh in
uh
2009, Holly and I got married and
started M&H Land and Cattle. And uh
we've been on this place for
uh since then, I guess. And uh when we
got married a little bit before that, JP
and his brother had operated together.
And Jake and I took over the operation.
Our main parts of the operation are cow
calf pair. Uh we background cattle and
we're working getting ready to feed
cattle fats and we also uh do row crops.
That's kind of GP's area. So we raise
corn, soybeans, uh winter wheat, spring
wheat. Uh this year we grew food grade
oats for Gerber baby food. Um we do hay
production. Um we have alalfa
uh cover crops. So this year uh well
previous years JP had had this idea to
bio strip till because in our area a lot
of aronomists uh push strip till and so
we and for the kind of ground that we
run it just doesn't really work that
well. um because we have have what JP
calls prairie potholes and it truly is
prairie potholes. Um and so we didn't
feel comfortable putting that dollars
and that fertilizer out there not
knowing that we would or wouldn't be
able to use it. So a few years ago JP
said, "Hey, what do you think about
using cover crops to try to do what
strip till
does, hey, I think it sounds good, but
it was really dry for a couple years
when it came time to plant them. So we
waited it out and this year it worked
out perfect. And so that's what we we
did. And so hopefully that'll that'll
prove out for us in in our rotation. All
right. What we have here is some noil
soil cloud here and we have some
conventional soil cloud here. And we're
going to run a demonstration on soil
aggregate stability. As we drop these
in, we're going to notice some bubbling
out of the no till, but not near as
rapidly as the conventional.
conventional till is starting to fall
apart rapidly. And so what this is
stimulating is is
a
a heavy rain
scenario that this soil here will erode
and kind of run down the furrow maybe
along with your high dollar seed or
fertilizer
where this is holding
together and actually
absorbing taking in that that moisture.
here.
Oh, wow. Now, look at it go.
I I'm surprised that that I thought I'd
be able to pull a chunk out of there in
2 minutes and break it in half and it
would still it would be dry in the
middle.
Oh, wow.
It's pretty much it's wet all the way
through. I mean, there's definitely
moisture pretty well all the way
through. And this one's completely gone.
This soil can hold this soil can hold
moisture. And this
soil, that's what we need is we have to
we have to have the ability to to
conserve moisture. And that's a integral
part of that. We say especially in our
area, which it's true, especially in our
area, but I mean, you think about across
the nation, California, they're putting
water restrictions on. I mean, it's just
a matter of time. It moves across the
country. So, it really is important no
matter where you live. Thanks a lot for
uh joining us with that little
experiment.
Um, like we said, we're we're located in
east central South Dakota and right uh
south of Zel, South Dakota. And and keep
looking for these little guys and these
little guys. Uh, I'm Holly Haver. This
is Haven. And I'm JP. And Harley's
taking a nap. Stop in if you're near
Zel. Thanks,
[Music]